I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hey there.
Today we're talking about christening, which is season 7, episode 7, written by Peter Ocho and directed by Alex Hardcastle. How about a summary? I thought you'd never ask. It is Cece Halpert's christening and The Whole Office shows up to the dismay of Jim and Pam. Michael is not the godfather, but during a post-christening reception with Too Little Food he is moved by the spirit of the church parishioners and impulsively joins a youth ministry trip to Mexico.
And Andy goes too. I mean, The Whole Office shows up because Michael invited them. Yes. Not Jim and Pam. Michael invited them. And they didn't know better not to come. I know. Like, aren't you like, huh, weird that Jim and Pam didn't invite me, but Michael did,
I guess I'll go. I mean, it's really sweet that everyone showed up, actually. It is, but I don't think Jim and Pam invited them. Fast fact number one, both our writer and our director are new on this episode. Yeah. Let's start with our director, Alex Hardcastle. He is a British television director and producer. He has directed such shows as New Girl, The Mindy Project, Crazy Ex-Girlfriend, and Grace
and Frankie. He was recommended by our executive producer, Howard Klein. And I remember him well. He was delightful. He was so charming. You guys, he had a really cute accent. I mean, we were such suckers for the accents. Charles McDougal.
I know. Idris. Alex Hardcastle. I know. Randy said he worked with Alex on other productions after the office, and he was always awesome. Now let's talk about Peter, our writer. He was a new writer on staff with us for season seven. And he had previously written on Dead Like Me and Pushing Daisies.
And Peter was quoted in Andy Green's book about the office, and he specifically talked about the christening episode. Oh, what'd he say? He said, quote, when I first started, they had this idea for a christening episode, which is as unsexy an episode as you can possibly pitch. And when they brought it up, the entire room looked at me because I had a lot of kids. And that's true. He had five kids.
He has a big family. And then he said, I think the thought was, we'll let him write it. And I felt this sense of how do you keep what we all loved in Jim and Pam in this post-marriage post-baby world. But he said they just tried to lean into it and acknowledge that the office was as much of a family for Jim and Pam in season seven as it was for Michael. And so that's where they got the idea that in the christening episode, you would bring the office into that story.
Yeah. I can imagine your first writing assignment, the christening, to be a little tough. I love hearing all of that. My memory of Peter is that he was so nice and I was a big fan of Dead Like Me. So I was like, oh my gosh, that's such a cool show. And now we get one of the writers from that show. One of the fun parts about working in this industry is that you get to run into people you're fans of and you get to hear all the inside scoop about what went into making this
show or movie that you love so much. Do you want Fast Back 2? Can I guess what it is? What is it? Because we're becoming like that old married couple in the pond. Oh, no. I know what I order for dinner. Maybe.
I'm going to guess. Sam, you guessed too. Okay. Fast Back 2. I'm going to guess that it's a location breakdown of the church. History of christenings. Those are two good guesses, I think. Angela is correct.
Is it? Yes. Woohoo! We had a fan question from Faye B. in New Hampshire who wanted to know where were the church scenes filmed. It was beautiful. It was gorgeous. We shot at Church of the Angels in Pasadena and I want to give a shout out to the scout
Lindsay and her blog, quote, I'm not a stalker because she goes around to different like film and television locations. Okay. And then she writes a little history about them and she pulled together all this cool information on Church of the Angels. Let's hear it. So this church was built in 1889 and it is the oldest church in Pasadena. It was built by Mrs. Francis E. Campbell Johnston in memory of her husband, Alexander Robert
Campbell Johnston, who was one of the first settlers of Pasadena. He was British and the church's design was based on Holmby St. Mary's Church in Surrey. I was going to say it looks like an old sort of English country church. I thought you were going to say, it looks like Hornby St. Mary's. Yeah. Definitely. That would have been funnier. But it really did.
When I was looking at it, I was like, oh, all the old stone and all of that. Yeah. Well, speaking of stone, the very first cornerstone of the church was laid in place by Francis herself. It's an Episcopalian church and I don't know if you remember this, Ange, but there's a large pipe organ inside the church. It is functional. It was built in 1889 by the Roosevelt Organ Works in New York City.
This church has been featured in a lot of film and television. It has appeared on Knott's Landing, which is why Lindsay stalked it. She was a Knott's Landing fan. It has also appeared on Desperate Housewives, The X-Files, Buffy the Vampire Slayer, the West Wing, Jag, the Mick Jagger God Gave Me Everything I Want music video, the Movies Just Married, Heather's, and, of course, The Office. That church has a longer resume than I do. That's impressive.
And incidentally, our base camp with all our trailers was in the Rose Bowl parking lots. Well, I loved that location breakdown. Thank you. Thank you, Lindsay, for blogging about it. Couldn't find your last name. Last fact number three is all about our amazing guest star, Zoe Jarman, who played Carla. Carla. Carla.
I mean, when she popped up, I immediately started giggling because we were so taken with her when we were shooting. She was so fantastic in her scenes with Steve. She held him toe to toe. Zoe, I was so excited to rewatch these scenes. I could not find Zoe on Instagram or Twitter or anywhere social media. Respect, Zoe. Whenever I can't find somebody, I'm always like, oh, they're a real actor.
I do. And so I could not slide into her DMs. Zoe, if you hear this, we would have loved to spoken to you. If you ever do get a social media slide into our DMs. Yes, it's an invitation. Well, let me tell you a little bit about Zoe. She is a comedian, sketch performer, and also a writer and director. She studied theater at Northwestern University in Chicago.
And she also studied at both Upright Citizens Brigade and the Groundlings. I am sure a lot of people know her as Betsy in the first two seasons of the Mindy Project. And that was a role that she got thanks to this guest role on The Office. I did find an interview with her where she said this. No, quote, I knew Mindy a bit before the show through the comedy community. She's been really supportive and kind to me in the times that I had gotten to be around her. Then she was really nice to me when I was on the set of The Office and made me feel
really welcome. Zoe said she had a really positive experience doing The Office and was really happy with the way her part turned out in the episode. Well, Zoe, we loved you. And I kept hoping for some kind of wrap up to Carla's story. Like I wanted to hear how it went. I mean, I would have loved if like in season eight, someone got a card from her from Carla in Mexico.
Well that's all I got for Fast Facts. Well, I have a fan catch. I'd love to hear it. This starts the beginning of a new DVD. You know, I'm watching the DVDs. New DVD. Mm-hmm. It's very exciting.
Clearly, it's more exciting for me, Jenna's looking at me with such a blank expression. I get very excited, Jenna, when I finish a DVD and I set it aside and I go get the next one. I have commented on the DVDs before. Okay. Clearly, I've brought it up too much, but I have a fan catch from Sam S. from Canada. Sam says in the delivery, Jim announced that their daughter's name is Cecilia, C.C. for short.
I have the DVD box set, and on the description for the christening episode, it says that her name is Celeste, quote, it's overcrowded at Jim and Pam's christening for baby Celeste when everyone from The Office shows up. But then throughout the rest of the show, she's referred to as Cecilia or C.C. Was this a production error? Oh, it had to have been. What did your DVD say, Angela? My DVD said the same.
Celeste. What? Does anyone else's DVD say Celeste? Happening. I think there was a little bit of an oops. There was an oopsie. Mm-hmm. Sam, I want you to know that you have made Angela's day.
Yes, you have, Sam. You have also scrutinized your DVDs, and that makes Angela's heart happy. It really does, and for anyone else that got a DVD box set that says Celeste, let us know. I think Sam and I need to know. Mm-hmm. Speaking of baby C.C., guess what I have thanks to Joya Balfour from NBC.com. Lady, I hope you're going to tell me that you have Pam's christening blog because I couldn't find it, but I remembered it existed.
Yes, I have it. Joya sent it to me. Here's how it read, C.C.'s christening, posted by Pam Halpert on November 4th, 2010 at 19.42 hours. 19.42 hours. Okay. Yeah. You know, you're minus 12, so I posted it at 7.42 p.m.
Didn't say. Well, that's what the 17 is. Oh, right. That's why we're doing military time. Yeah. Right. So that you don't have to worry about. So you don't have to worry if it's AM or PM.
Right. Because you know it's in the number. When you're in a stressful situation. Yes. Yes. And that way, if things are going down, you know it's nighttime and not the morning. Yeah. Okay.
Here's what it said. Okay. 7.42 p.m. It's official. C.C. is a member of the Covenant community. The baptism ceremony was beautiful, mostly. C.C. looked so cute in her christening gown, she was almost in it long enough to get a picture. It was wonderful to see all of our friends and family at the church.
My apologies to everyone that went to the reception. We promise that C.C.'s wedding will be catered. Although the day didn't go as smoothly as planned, all in all, it was a truly blessed event. I know all babies are equal in the eyes of the Lord, but C.C. was definitely the cutest baby there. Aw. Aw.
Very sweet. Pam's baby blog. Who is she writing this for? It's like who I used to write my journals for. Yeah. I don't know who's reading her blog. I might have brought a journal today. Please say yes.
What? Yes. I found one of my journals. What? All right. We're going to take a break. Uh-huh. We're going to come back and break down this episode.
And at some point, Angela will be getting out her journal. Oh, I can see it. Oh my God. I can see it. I just took it out. What? Wait. I just need Jenna to read.
I just need Jenna to read what's on the front of my journal. I am here to live out loud. Yes. Yes, I am, guys. Yes, I am. And when we come back, we're going to break down the christening, get into my journal, and who knows what else. I have a present for you.
You do? Oh my gosh. There's so much to do today. We'll be right back. This episode starts with Pam in her role as office administrator, and she is leading a conference room meeting all about hygiene. Yeah, and she's got a big sign. If you go to 12 seconds, it says Saber Hygiene Day, semicolon, simple steps to a cleaner
working environment. Please wash your hands, remember to get your flu shot, wipe down your desk daily, stay home when you are sick or contagious, use the hand sanitizing station often. Dwight isn't happy about the hand sanitizing stations, or any of these suggestions, really. He says that the best way to not get sick is to be exposed to germs, and he would like a hand desanitizing station. Did you hear what he wants in his hand desanitizing station? No, I missed it.
He wants, and I quote, a simple bowl at every juncture filled with dirt, vomit, fecal matter, and then he gets cut off. What? What the heck? This got me curious because Pam said, according to a study done by the University of Arizona, they discovered that your keyboards have hundreds of times more bacteria per square inch than a toilet seat. That's true.
It is true. I know. So does your phone, by the way. Oh, I went to WebMD. Are you ready for the top five most germy places in an office? Yeah. Number one, elevator buttons. Many of them don't work as we've learned.
Stop touching them. Who cares? Number two, door handles. Number three, your actual desk, like your actual desktop. Number four, your keyboard. Number five, your telephone. Is this a good time to tell you that when I go into a hotel room or something, I wipe down the remote and the light switches and everything with a little antibacterial wipe
because I watched a whole whatever date line or something like that all about it. I feel like we all saw that date line where they went in with that special light and everything glowed blue because it was poop or earwax or something disgusting. The most disturbing part of that show for me was when they showed secret cameras of how they don't really clean the water glasses that are left in the bathrooms. A lot of places, they just rinsed them under water using the same rag that they had just used to clean the bathroom. I never use those cups.
Okay. I don't. Well, I've been using them, but I might not anymore. I put my makeup brushes in them. I don't drink out of them. That's a no for me. Okay. Well, just saying.
It's a new no for me. Well, Pam also suggests that you should cough into your elbow as a great way to prevent the spreading of germs or sneeze into your elbow like the Dracula. Yeah, the vampire cough. And I read some studies on that and that is good advice. Yeah. You should do that. I love our kids to do that at school.
And now all my kids cough like that. Well, Dwight says that he would rather people just cough or sneeze directly on him. So we have a montage of people sneezing on him, his food, all kinds of things. We got a fan question from Rosie S. in Edinburgh, Scotland, who said, I spotted a small error in the cold open. What Rosie? Dwight talks about the cost of wool in Transylvania and he blames it on the Euro. But Rosie points out that Transylvania is in Romania, which does not use the Euro.
It's in Europe, but they have their own currency. Dwight. And they have for a while. Now I believe they are converting to the Euro in a few years, however. Dwight got it wrong. That's rare. Dwight, often we find, has got it right, but not this time. The episode starts outside of the church, Angela is walking up to Jim and Pam and they're
holding little Cece. Yeah, the whole office is kind of congregated outside before the ceremony begins. And I'll have you know, Angela, we shot this episode the week of September 13, 2010. And we are recording this podcast almost exactly 12 years later in September, 2022. That is crazy. Now you know what the temperature is today, right? Oh yeah, it's like 103. Yes.
We did all of these exterior scenes outside this church in heavy wool coats, pretending it was fall because this aired in November, but luckily it was only 83 degrees. But still, when you watch all of these scenes outside the church, just know that we are very hot. We did not put a coat on baby Cece on purpose. We did not want to overheat the baby. But Pam is in a wool coat. Well, I got so tickled rewatching these scenes, Jenna, because I had so much fun being so
sweet to the baby and so snarky to Jim and Pam. I know, I really loved those turns every time. I even went to the shooting draft, Jenna, to see if there was stage direction about it. And it said, Angela is cold to Jim and Pam and cutesy to Cece. And you know, Jenna, in this episode, I have two improv lines that made it in. Oh, I think I know one of them. Well, the first one comes in this little couplet of dialogue when Angela turns to Jim and Pam
and she goes, Jim, Pam, and the precious bundle of God's gift to everything. And then she goes back to Jim and Pam. I wish you both a pleasant day. And then I am provised. And you too. Yes, praise God. Okay. Aw.
I just couldn't get enough of those little girls. Those babies were so cute. People just turned into jelly around those babies. I know. They were the sweetest. Once again, they were played by Bailey and Sienna, although there were a few times that we used the creepy jelly baby. Oh, I caught it.
Yeah. Phil got it for us. They're really expensive. We've talked about these before. They're like thousands of dollars. And we had to be careful with them. I have some catches. I have some jelly baby catches.
I do too. But in these opening scenes, it was all Bailey and Sienna. You know, in the shooting draft, there's a series of talking heads where everyone would have weighed in on whether or not they want kids. Oh. Yeah. But Andy, saying that he wanted nard pups, is the one that made it in, and it's definitely the best one.
Well, as everyone's entering the church, Dwight is going to hand out his business cards. And you know what cracked me up about this moment, Jenna? It's very small, but Rain chose to deliver the line where he hands the business cards in the way that when you walk into church, they hand you the program. Yes. I thought it was so great. He was like Dwight Schrute, regional sales, Dwight Schrute business card, like he did that cadence.
Yes. This was part of a bigger storyline for Dwight. It's in deleted scenes. It comes out throughout the episode where he is really trying to work this church crowd for business. Well the one person who's having trouble getting into the church is Toby. He says it's been a few years since he's attended a church service. Yeah.
He and the big guy have some catching up to do. I went to deleted scenes and looked in our candy bag alts because I was curious if there was any more backstory. I mean, we learned in season five, Casual Friday, that Toby had been in seminary and dropped out because he wanted to have sex with his girlfriend, Kathy. Yes. And then followed her to Scranton and took the first job he could find, which was in human resources at Dunder Mifflin.
Well, I'm curious what you found because we had fan questions from Rachel C. and Suffolk, Virginia, and Kayleigh E. in Indianapolis, Indiana, who said, so Toby has trouble going into the church, but wasn't he at Jim and Pam's wedding as well as Phyllis's wedding? He didn't have a problem going into those churches. Oh, that's such a good catch. Well the candy bag alts were all versions of this. Here's one of them. Toby, I studied for the ministry, but well, it didn't work out.
So I'm going to walk into the church, maybe look up at the altar and say, hey, remember me? It's Toby. Okay. They were all versions of that, that he left the church and there was some mystery and he's got a little bit of beef, maybe with the big man. You know where my brand went? What?
You know who wouldn't want to enter a church because they have a problem with God? Who? A strangler. Oh! And he started strangling after Jim and Pam's wedding and Phyllis's wedding. Yep. Sam. Sam.
Toby the Scranton Strangler. Will the Reddit threads be a buzz with this new development? Michael of course is going to try to weasel his way into the family sitting area at the church. I mean, this is what he does. Remember Phyllis's wedding? He wanted to be in the family photo and he's doing his Godfather impression and I loved this line so much, Jenna.
You said, you know, I love it when you do that voice, but today I'm sorry, I need you to tell me that you know you're not CC's Godfather. And then Michael's like, yeah, and Pam says, I'm sorry, Michael, I need you to say it. I'm so sorry. I have to say that exchange sort of reminded me a little bit of Carol stills. Yes. I felt like it was something Carol would say to Michael. Yes.
Michael, we're breaking up. I need you to know that. And I need you to say it back to me. Yeah, exactly. Well, I don't know if you noticed, but little CC is holding a little toy in her hand through all these scenes. I did. It's like a little tiger.
So that was a real little toy. I don't know if it was Bailey or Santa in the scene, but it was just a great way to help make her feel secure. That was something that we did sometime. We just let them carry their own blankies or their own little toys. Yeah. You know, something that is revealed in the scene, Angela, is that the Godfather of Jim and Pam's baby is their friend, Seth, whose wife Pam met at mommy and me.
I mean, isn't that sort of just like a quick turnaround to Godfather status? Fan mail flurry, Angela. So many people wrote in to say, why did Pam and Jim choose two people they essentially just met to be CC's godparents rather than one of their siblings or even an old friend? I am part of the fan mail flurry. Well, this made me wonder, hey, where is Pam's sister? Yeah, this is a big moment. This is a big moment for Pam.
I know. Also, where's her friend, Isabel? Yeah. I mean, a lot of people are no shows. Jim's brothers. Yeah. They all live in town. It's not like these people had to travel far.
I don't know. Maybe, you know, we did have a lot of guest stars in this episode. Maybe we just couldn't pack anybody else in. Well, I'm with Michael. Michael's like, he can't believe that these two in his eyes, random people, are going to hold such a huge part in CC's life. We never find out the godmother's name. It's just Seth and his wife.
Hmm. Anyway, well, the pastor is going to welcome everyone. I loved this scene. It just reminded me so much of Sundays during football season and church because the pastor says what a terrific day this is and not just because the Eagles are playing and Kevin is so tickled. This is like the biggest laugh that he's had in a while. We had a fan question from Kirsten L. in Minnesota.
I really appreciate that the church pastor was cast as female. As someone who is considering becoming a Lutheran pastor myself, there aren't many women pastors depicted in the media. I'm wondering how this came about. Was Alison Jones looking for a woman specifically for this role? Is this woman an actual pastor? Well, Kirsten, the script called for a woman to play this role. Minister Gale was played by an actress named Carolyn Wilson.
She's also appeared in Veep and Space Force. And get this, she was the casting associate for that 70s show, including the episode in which I played Stacey Wanamaker. Huh. Yeah. Well, I thought Carolyn did a great job. So believable. I mean, I would have believed she was a real pastor.
I mean, I was like, I want to hear her sermon. Well, as part of her welcoming everyone to church that day, the pastor is also going to share with us that their young adult ministry is going to be leaving for Mexico. And they all like applaud. They're very excited. And they're also going to have their prayers and remembrance section. Yes. Justin's mom, who was played by Sarah Zinser, is just going to ask everyone to keep Justin
in their thoughts and in their prayers. And then there's going to be a standoff for who speaks next. Because both Dwight and a gentleman stand up at the same time and Dwight stares the man down until he sits, which was an amazing moment in my opinion. Well, Dwight is now going to just basically hit everyone up to buy a printer. It's like so inappropriate. And I have a jelly baby catch. Oh, is it at five minutes and 55 seconds?
Yeah. Yes. In this whole scene, I had jelly baby and I hope you noted some of the ways that I was trying to move jelly baby to make it look like it was a real baby. You were like bobbing her on your knee. Yeah. And like kind of like moving her arm with my thumb. Mm hmm.
Lady, this reminded me of the most famous jelly baby in a movie. Do you remember it? Oh, I do. I do. I do. Wait, no, I've got it. Because Josh and I were like, this is ridiculous. This is a big budget movie.
Wait, wait, wait. No, I have it. Oh, wait. I can see the guy's face. Bradley Cooper. Yes, Bradley Cooper in American Sniper. Yes. He's holding this baby that is so fake.
He does a lot of the same kind of jelly baby stuff I was doing like there's one part. I rewatched it where you see him take his thumb and move the baby's arm. But this is like an emotional scene. Yeah. And that baby was so distracting and I feel like he was doing a really good performance but all I could look at was this jelly baby. When this came out and it was all over the news, I found an audio clip. There's plenty of buzz and controversy surrounding American Sniper moving towards the convoy.
But this morning moviegoers are highlighting one glaring issue in particular. Do you see it? The baby. It's a fake. It's a prop doll. One minute and 13 seconds, Bradley Cooper pats, cuddles, cradles and oh so gently lays down that fake baby. Now Twitter erupting with the hashtag fake baby with posts like, did they not trust Bradley
Cooper with a real baby? And had CPR class the other morning, found the baby used in American Sniper. So I can't remember who it is but someone associated with the movie tweeted but then deleted why they used the fake baby. What was the tweet? It said something like the real baby showed up with a fever and then the second baby didn't show up and so they had to just use fake baby and do their best. Why do you have to delete that tweet?
That's just information. I don't know. I guess maybe it was like not his place to say why there was a fake baby. I don't know. Maybe the studio was like, don't call out the fake baby. Yeah, exactly. Enough with the fake baby. I loved that clip from the news so much because I loved how many different stings were in
there, Sam. Did you hear them? There was like the screech and the glass breaking and like, I don't know, was there a helicopter? It was like a zoo time radio. Yeah, there were so many things. Well I have a great photo of our jelly baby. It was in between scenes.
It was pretty hot because they kept turning off the air when we would film. I was in the main part of the church sitting area. You were up on the dais and I looked over at you and you looked at me and the jelly baby had flopped over, kind of falling off your lap and I took your picture. It's in our book, The Office BFFs. It cracks me up every time I see it. I love that we have that picture because jelly baby was a big part of my life starting now till the end of the show.
Yeah, you spent a lot of time with jelly baby. And then you did too. And then I did too. And jelly babies are heavy and if you're hot, they can also make you more hot. Oh, we got another fan question from Angela V in Ontario, Canada who asked, who picked the hymns for this episode? Also Jim Devere sings. He's laughing with Pam.
Oh, okay, good catch. Randy said most of the hymns were chosen because they were public domain with the exception of one, which was, with grateful hearts, our faith professing, that was scripted and it cost $5,000 to license about the cost of a jelly baby. Well, I think it's time for a break and we have a few things outstanding. We have a journal. Yep. We have a gift.
Yes. Baby Cece needs a whole new outfit. Yep. Let's take a break and get to it. And someone stole the scones. I won't say who. What? I didn't steal them.
Someone else put them in my bag. All right, we are back and Cece's diaper needs a change. But before we do that, Angela, I want to give you your gift. Oh, okay. All right. Here it is. I wrapped it. You really did.
So, you know, we shared with everyone last week that we got desks and that we opened the mail. Wait, before you look. What? I don't know. I want to give it. I thought I was allowed to open it. Okay.
I just want to say, what have you been saying you wish you had? A letter opener, because there's so many letters. Yes. And I've been opening them with my little finger and I snag that little side part of your fingernail. So, here, this is my special letter opener for you. Oh, the Night's Watch. Wait, it's a Game of Thrones.
Yeah. It's a Game of Thrones letter opener. Oh my gosh, it is the Long Claw Sword Letter Opener. Yes. Yay. Winter is coming and so is your mail. So here's the thing. I really wanted to get Aria's sword for you.
By the way, I don't know anything about what I'm saying. I did a lot of Googling to figure out, like, what Game of Thrones item. This is one of the most thoughtful gifts you've ever given me in all of our friendship. I mean, they don't, from what I know, make Aria's sword into a letter opener. The Needle. It's called the Needle. The Needle. Yes.
You can get a replica of it for your house, but you can't open letters with it. So I hope that this Long Claw Sword is good. Yes, I love it. I will take a picture of it and I will open mail happily with it. Something that keeps coming up in our mail. I'm holding up my letter opener. Something that keeps coming up in our mail is, what is next for office ladies? What are we doing next?
Are we going to be ladies who Google? Are we going to be mom detectives? What's our next podcast? Are we going to do movies? I know, lady. This is the question because I can't believe, what do we have like a year? OMG. I know.
I like it here. I want to keep doing this with you. I love our office ladies family. I know me too. So we do need to figure out what's next. I think we should, we should try some stuff out. That's how we got here, right? Yeah.
We put the phone between us and we started chatting. What should we do next? Like a bonus episode on a Monday or something. This has gotten bigger. I thought we were going to be in your garage again, but yes, you're right. We could. What are we going to do? Just sit and record and not play it for anyone?
Okay, you're right. You're right. Okay, yes, I like this bonus episode, but what should we talk about? I like the idea of doing maybe, let's break down a movie. Ooh. What movie? Ooh. Should we put it in office ladies pod?
People can weigh in. What movie, guys? What movie? Why are you even asking this question? It's so obvious that this movie is- Is John Wick? Yes. Or Stars, Keanu Reeves.
Oh, what about speed? Oh, I love speed. That's how I started on my Keanu journey. That was your introduction to Keanu? Yes. That was my gateway drug into Keanu. Pop quiz. Yeah.
Come on. I'm ready. Oh, and we know Beth Grant. Oh, she would give us all the inside info on sitting on that bus, I'm sure. Beth Grant played Dwight's babysitter slash date to dinner party. She was also on the bus in speed. Oh, guys, it's coming together. I feel very inspired by this speed idea.
Should we put it to a vote though? Because I would love to point out some background details in John Wick that I know you missed, a.k.a. the coffee maker, a.k.a. Excuse me, do not even come to me. You're going to want to back away from that statement about things I missed when the first time you ever watched it, you stopped watching it 15 minutes. This is the other podcast idea we could do, just the first 15 minutes of every movie. We call it Jenna's Breakdown.
Well, I would thrive on that podcast because I'm very good at watching the first 15 to 20 minutes of a film. I know. And then you fall asleep. But I come back. You do. In the days that follow. Okay.
Well, we should get back to this episode. That's lost to think about. And it all started with my letter opener. Thank you. What a gift. What a gift. That letter opener may lead to our next thing. Who knew?
Who knew? But that is the power of the long-claw sword, clearly. I don't know what I'm talking about, but is that true? Does that hold power? I hope I willed it with the justice it deserves. Let's pivot back into this episode because Cece has pooped all over her christening dress. And Jim is going to hustle out to his car. This was such a real dad moment for me.
He's looking desperately. And of course, Pam has packed a backup outfit. Yeah. Jim said that he saw it in there. He checked. He didn't bring it. Yeah. He did say that, is what he says.
There's two lines that Jim has that made me laugh so hard as a parent. First of all, he says to Pam, this is happening because you've had those moments where one parent is already halfway down the road and they're bringing the other one up to speed and they're like, this is happening. Trust me. This was our best option, was this t-shirt. So we're going to go from here. And then she's like, no, there's this backup outfit.
吉姆有两句台词，作为父母，我当时笑得前仰后合。首先，他对帕姆说，事情会变成这样是因为你经历过那种时刻：一个家长已经走了一半路，然后把另一个家长叫来了解情况，他们会说，事情就是这样，相信我。
You said you checked the bag. And he's like, I did say that. That's what I said. Maybe not what I did. So I loved those. And I personally was charmed by the fact that all of their photos from the day would have CeCe in this t-shirt. That would just become fun family lore, in my opinion.
你不是说你检查过包了吗？然后他回答说，我是说过。我是这么说的。可能不代表我是这么做的。所以我很喜欢这些桥段。而且我个人觉得特别迷人的一点是，他们当天的所有照片里，西西都穿着这件 T 恤。在我看来，这会变成一段有趣的家庭佳话。
If that happened to my kids, they would be so delighted to look at those pictures and hear that story again. Oh, for sure. It would be like, right? Yeah. Like you can't get too upset over these moments. Well, the christening is over and Stanley thinks he can go, but the pastor's going to let everyone know that the Halberts are hosting a reception next door.
如果这种事发生在我孩子身上，他们看到这些照片，再次听到这个故事，一定会觉得特别高兴。哦，那是肯定的。就好像，对吧？对啊。所以你没必要为这些时刻太心烦。好吧，洗礼结束了，斯坦利以为他可以走了，但牧师却通知大家，哈珀夫妇正在隔壁举办招待会。
For everyone. Yep. Everyone's invited. Well, this mistake really angered Chelsea L from Houston, Texas. I want to say that in Chelsea's letter, there are a lot of all caps. Chelsea, what got you was at the Halbert. It was so many things. Here is what Chelsea said, quote, OK, this bothers me so much every time I see this episode.
所有人都有份。没错。所有人都被邀请了。嗯，这个失误真的惹恼了来自得克萨斯州休斯顿的切尔西·L。我想说的是，切尔西的信里有很多全大写的字母。切尔西，戳中你痛点的是在哈珀那儿吗？事情实在太多了。切尔西是这么说的，引述如下，“好吧，每次我看这一集，这件事都让我超级烦恼。”
Why does Jim not correct the minister when she announces the Halbert reception? Come on, Jim. Or Pam. I suppose Pam could have corrected this, too. And I don't think anyone in the church would be angry if they corrected the minister and asked folks not to come to the reception unless they knew Jim and Pam. This makes me so irrationally angry for them, Chelsea. But Jim and Pam do not correct the minister, instead, they are now going to host a reception
为什么吉姆在牧师宣布哈珀招待会时不去纠正她？拜托，吉姆。或者帕姆。我想帕姆其实也可以纠正这个错误。而且我觉得如果他们纠正了牧师，并请大家除非认识吉姆和帕姆，否则不要来参加招待会，教堂里的任何人也都不会生气的。这让我替他们感到莫名的愤怒，切尔西。但吉姆和帕姆并没有纠正牧师，相反，他们现在要主持一场招待会。
for which they do not have enough food. Well, this is kind of a recurring thing with Jim's last name, because it happened in Niagara as well. Remember outside of the reception, there was a sign that said the Hal Pritt reception? This happens to me all the time. People put an L in my last name, so they'll say Kinsley. I've heard people call you Kinsley over and over. It is time for the reception.
而他们准备的食物根本不够。好吧，这在吉姆的姓氏上算是一个老梗了，因为在尼亚加拉瀑布那次也发生过。大家还记得招待会外面那个写着“哈普里特”招待会的牌子吗？这种事经常发生在我身上。人们总是在我的姓氏里加一个 L，所以他们会叫我金斯利。我听过无数次别人叫你金斯利了。招待会的时间到了。
It is very crowded. Angela is going to clock this right away. And I have one of my lines that is quoted to me coming up. I have seen it stitched on a pillow. Angela says to Pam, you don't know them all. Pam says, nope. And we're going to need a loaves and fishes kind of miracle to feed them all. And that's when Angela says, Jesus is not your caterer.
现场非常拥挤。安吉拉马上就注意到这一点了。接下来这句台词经常有人对我引用。我甚至看过有人把它绣在抱枕上。安吉拉对帕姆说：“你并不认识他们所有人。”帕姆说：“没错。”“而我们需要一个‘五饼二鱼’式的神迹才能喂饱所有人。”就在这时，安吉拉说：“耶稣可不是你的餐饮供应商。”
But he should be your caterer, because you're a little angel. Why didn't your parents get you a caterer? And now, do you know what I improvised? Because they don't think. It was so southern. When I heard it, I was like, they don't think. Everyone is hungry. Everyone is angry.
但他的确应该是你的餐饮供应商，因为你是个可爱的小天使。你父母怎么没给你请个餐饮供应商？现在，你知道我即兴发挥了什么吗？因为他们根本不走脑子。这太有南方特色了。我当时一听就觉得，他们脑子真是不转。每个人都很饿。每个人都很生气。
There's a lot of angry folks at this reception. Well, Angela isn't the only person who's miffed at the lack of food. We also have to deal with Doug McPherson Davies' uncle. It's one of my favorite character names. He was played by Emil Beheshti, who is a very accomplished comedic actor. He's been on Will and Grace, the King of Queens, Gregg the Bunny, Grounded for Life, Big Love. The list goes on and on. Even after finding out there's not really any food, everyone is still staying.
这场招待会上有很多愤怒的人。好吧，安吉拉并不是唯一一个对食物短缺感到恼火的人。我们还要对付道格·麦克弗森·戴维斯的叔叔。这是我最喜欢的角色名字之一。他由埃米尔·贝希斯蒂饰演，他是一位非常有成就的喜剧演员。他曾出演过《威尔与格蕾丝》、《皇后区之王》、《格雷格小兔》、《余生无憾》、《大爱》等作品。这样的例子不胜枚举。即使发现其实没有什么吃的，大家还是留了下来。
Leave everybody. Just go away. My favorite grump was Sconesy Cider. Sconesy Cider, lady. There is a Twitter page for Sconesy Cider. No way. Yes. It is basically a bunch of posts about Cider and Scones.
大家都走吧。赶紧离开。我最喜欢的怪脾气老太太是斯康西·西代尔。斯康西·西代尔女士。推特上甚至还有一个关于斯康西·西代尔的主页。真的假的？真的。那基本上是一个全是关于苹果酒和司康饼的帖子账号。
Also, if you'd like a Sconesy Cider bumper sticker, you can find one over on the Etsy page. That's what Soap said. We even got a fan question from Patrick R. in Ailsbury, UK, who said, I did a mini deep dive on Sconesy Cider and I find out that if someone questions where the food and drink is at at a party, you call them a Sconesy Cider. It's a whole thing. That is awesome.
另外，如果你想要一个斯康西·西代尔的车用贴纸，你可以在Etsy页面上找到一个。索普就是这么说的。我们甚至收到了来自英国艾尔斯伯里的粉丝帕特里克·R的一个问题，他说：“我对斯康西·西代尔进行了一次微型深度研究，我发现如果有人在派对上质疑食物和饮料在哪里，你就可以称他们为‘斯康西·西代尔’。这成了一个梗。”太棒了。
We've got to start using Sconesy Cider. Why haven't we been using that all this time? No, because we haven't done this rewatch yet and now we have and now we have a new catch phrase. Yep. Don't be a Sconesy Cider. Don't be a Sconesy Cider. She's amazing.
我们得开始使用“斯康西·西代尔”这个词了。为什么我们以前一直没用过？不，因为我们还没做过这次重温，现在我们做了，而且我们现在有了一个新的流行语。没错。别当个斯康西·西代尔。别当个斯康西·西代尔。她太棒了。
Well, Sconesy Cider was played by actress Stephanie McVeigh. She's been on Parks and Rec and Superstore and like a gazillion things because she's fantastic. I didn't point it out earlier, but she had a great background detail in the church. It's at eight minutes and 25 seconds Sconesy Cider is putting on powder with a little compact. So you know, before she gets up to go to the reception to be disappointed by the lack of food she is going to powder her face. Carla is going to stand up and give a really great speech about the youth ministry and she thanks Jim and Pam for hosting them because after this reception, they're going to Mexico.
好吧，斯康西·西代尔由女演员斯蒂芬妮·麦克维饰演。她演过《公园与游憩》、《超级商店》以及成百上千部作品，因为她太优秀了。我刚才没有指出来，但她在教堂的背景里有一个很棒的细节。在第八分钟二十五秒时，斯康西·西代尔正拿着一个小粉盒往脸上扑粉。所以你看，在她起身去招待会面对食物短缺而感到失望之前，她要先扑个粉。卡拉将站起来，发表一篇关于青年事工的精彩演讲，她感谢吉姆和帕姆接待他们，因为招待会结束后，他们就要去墨西哥了。
They're going to spend three months building a school. Yes, and Michael is really inspired by the joy that's sort of emanating from this youth ministry table and nobody else is taking it seriously. We got table of sass, basically. So much sass and Michael is like, let's go build an airport. Okay, we'll start small with a car wash. Ryan is like spinning his iPad. What's up with Ryan and his iPad?
他们要去那里花三个月时间建一所学校。是的，迈克尔真的被青年事工这桌人散发出的那种快乐所感染了，而其他桌的人都没有把它当回事。基本上，我们迎来了毒舌之桌。满满的毒舌，迈克尔甚至说：“我们去建个机场吧。”好吧，我们从小事做起，先建个洗车行。瑞安一直在转他的iPad。瑞安和他的iPad是怎么回事？
This is the second thing he's brought it to that it's not appropriate. He brought it to Andy's play. Oh, yeah. You're right. And now here it is at the christening. Well, Michael is just like, guys, I don't get it. We should hang out more. Like I think he's seeing the fellowship of that table and he's seeing the lack of fellowship
这是他第二次把这东西带到不合时宜的场合了。他把它带到了安迪的话剧现场。哦，对。你说的对。现在它又出现在了洗礼仪式上。好吧，迈克尔就是那种状态：“伙计们，我搞不懂。我们应该多一起出去玩。”我觉得他看到了那一桌人的情谊，并对比看到了
at their table. And then Daryl has the best sass line. I loved it so much. He says, we are hanging out right now. You want some more of this? It's so good. I loved it. Michael is so bummed out by his table that he's going to storm out at 12 minutes 48 seconds.
他们这一桌人之间缺乏情谊。然后达里尔贡献了最毒舌的一句台词。我太喜欢了。他说：“我们现在不就在一块儿玩吗？你还想来点这个吗？”太棒了。我太喜欢了。迈克尔对自己的那一桌人感到无比沮丧，以至于他在12分48秒时气冲冲地夺门而出。
Did you see the sign as he leaves the reception hall? No. It says, Halbert christening reception. They made a whole sign? Yeah. Well, meanwhile, Pam is going to go out. She's going to grab some subs and sodas. Yeah.
他离开招待大厅时，你看到那个牌子了吗？没有。上面写着：哈珀洗礼招待会。他们居然专门做了一个牌子？对啊。好吧，与此同时，帕姆要出去了。她要去买些潜艇堡和苏打水。对。
Everyone's hungry. They need to get more food. Mm-hmm. Well, Jim is going to be looking for some chairs and he needs a place that's quiet for CeCe. Jim finds Mima on a little side room on a sofa, just sitting by herself. And this is what she has to say. Oh, hey, Mima, would you watch CeCe for a second?
大家都饿了。他们需要弄点吃的来。嗯哼。好吧，吉姆要去找几把椅子，而且他需要一个安静的地方照顾西西。吉姆在一个小侧间的沙发上找到了米玛，她正一个人坐着。这是她要说的话。哦，嘿，米玛，你能帮我照看一会儿西西吗？
Tell her she's asleep. I'm just going to track down some more chairs. Fine. Fine. I guess I'll watch Suzanne's purse and your baby. Watch Suzanne's purse and your baby and I want to say later when Jim comes back and he can't find CeCe, he comes into Mima again and he's like, Mima, where is CeCe? And she says, I lost the purse too.
告诉她她睡着了。我得去找几把椅子。好吧。好吧。我想我会帮苏珊看着她的钱包和你的孩子。帮苏珊看钱包和你的孩子，我想说的是，后来吉姆回来找不到了西西，他又遇到了米玛，他说：“米玛，西西去哪儿了？”她说：“我也把钱包弄丢了。”
Yeah. Yeah. She's so matter of fact, she's like, I don't know. It's so good. She doesn't even turn around and look at him. Well, like you said, Jim is on the hunt for some chairs, but we had a fan catch from Kristen H. in Austin, Texas, and Jesse T. from Chicago, Illinois, who said, when Jim gives CeCe to Pam's Mima, he says he's looking for chairs.
对。对。她太实事求是了，她就说：“我不知道。”太搞笑了。她甚至都没转过身去看他一眼。好吧，正如你所说，吉姆正在四处找椅子，但我们收到了来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的克里斯滕·H和伊利诺伊州芝加哥的杰西·T的粉丝抓包，他们说，当吉姆把西西交给帕姆的米玛时，他说他正在找椅子。
Why does he not just use the chairs right behind him in that room? Are those special holy church chairs? Lady, it's true. There is a dining table surrounded by chairs. And he walks right past them and says, I need to find some chairs. I didn't catch that. That's great. I thought maybe he's looking for some folding chairs or something, but there are clearly
他为什么不直接用那个房间里他身后的那些椅子呢？难道那是些特殊的圣洁教堂椅子吗？天哪，确实如此。那里明明有一张餐桌，周围围满了椅子。他从它们旁边径直走过，却说：“我得去找些椅子。”我当时没注意到这点。太棒了。我还以为他在找折叠椅什么的，但那里明明有
eight chairs right there. Didn't need to look so hard. Well, it is time for the youth ministry to leave. Their bus is waiting and people are gathering outside, kind of making a long line to give them high fives and hugs as they go. It kind of reminded me of like when a football team is entering the stadium and people give them the high five as they take the field. Yeah.
整整八把椅子就摆在那儿。根本没必要找得那么辛苦。好吧，青年事工的人该走了。他们的大巴在外面等候，人们聚在外面，排成长队，跟他们击掌拥抱送别。这让我想起了橄榄球队进入体育场时，大家在他们上场时跟他们击掌的情景。对。
And Michael joins right in. He's just very into it. He's wishing them all the best. He's really caught up in this and all of a sudden he's like, you know what, I'm going with him. Yep. And he gets on the bus. We had a fan catch from Maricela Kay in Riverside, California, who said at 13 minutes and 45
迈克尔也加入了进去。他完全沉浸其中。他祝愿他们一切顺利。他真的被这个氛围感染了，突然间他说：“你知道吗，我和你们一起去。”没错。然后他上了大巴。我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州里弗赛德的玛丽塞拉·K的粉丝抓包，她说在13分45
seconds, did anyone else notice that the camera crew was already on the bus and like in the back of the bus before Michael even got on? How did they know? I totally noticed that. I totally noticed that. And I was like, why is the camera crew on the bus? We had another question from Liam M. in Brisbane, Australia, who said, was there ever a discussion in the writer's room about the integrity of the camera crew?
秒时，有没有人注意到摄像团队已经在车上，而且在迈克尔上车之前就已经在车厢后部了？他们是怎么知道的？我完全注意到了。我真的注意到了。当时我就想，为什么摄像团队会在大巴上？我们还收到了来自澳大利亚布里斯班的利亚姆·M的另一个问题，他说：“编剧室里有没有讨论过摄像团队的底线和职业操守问题？”
Would they have really gone all the way to Mexico? Yeah. I thought the same thing. Oh my goodness. None of them have any bags, including Michael. And then our other volunteer, Andy. Well, Michael has a speech that he gives that cracked me up. Jenna Phyllis says, Michael, what am I supposed to tell my clients if they ask about you?
他们真的会一路跟到墨西哥去吗？对。我也这么想。哦天哪。他们谁都没带包，迈克尔也是。然后是我们的另一位志愿者安迪。好吧，迈克尔发表了一段让我笑岔气的演讲。詹娜·菲利斯说：“迈克尔，如果我的客户问起你，我该怎么回答？”
And Michael, leaning out of the window of the bus, says, tell them that I died. And I turned into an angel. And when they fill a breeze in a room with all the windows closed or that chill on the back of their neck, that is just me watching over them. And then Phyllis is like, okay, but what about the bigger corporate accounts? And Michael says, tell them I'm in a meeting. I loved all that too. And I love how Andy decides he's going as well.
迈克尔从大巴车窗探出头说：“告诉他们我死了。我变成了一天使。当他们在所有窗户都关着的房间里感觉到一阵微风，或者脖子后面感到一阵寒意时，那就是我在默默守护他们。”然后菲利斯说：“好吧，那那些规模更大的公司客户呢？”迈克尔说：“告诉他们我在开会。”我也超爱这些桥段。我更喜欢安迪决定他也要一起去。
There's a great thing in deleted scenes, so you know they give Michael a t-shirt. Michael's very excited. Oh, he puts it on. Yeah. Put under his suit jacket. Yeah. Over his shirt. Yes.
被删减的片段里有个很棒的细节，他们给了迈克尔一件T恤。迈克尔兴奋极了。哦，他把它穿上了。对。穿在他的西装外套里面。对。穿在衬衫外面。是的。
Andy, when he gets on the bus, is like, can I get a shirt? And they're like, we're all out. Here you can have a pin. And if you guys go to 15 minutes and 41 seconds, you can see the pin on Andy's like jacket. All of this talk about being on a bus and travel is making me think of my journal. Oh, is it time? It is time because I used to write a lot in my journal when I was traveling. Nothing like writing when you're on a bus or a plane.
安迪上了大巴后说：“我也能来一件T恤吗？”他们回答说：“我们发完了。这里有个徽章给你。”如果大家去看15分41秒，就能看到安迪夹克上的徽章。所有这些关于坐大巴和旅行的谈话让我想起了我的日记。哦，是时候了吗？是时候了，因为我以前旅行时在日记里写了很多东西。没有什么比坐在大巴或飞机上写作更有感觉了。
All right, Sam. Sam and I have both sat forward in our chairs with anticipation. Physically giddy. All right. You guys have a choice. Do you want to hear what I've titled anniversary or do you want to hear what I've titled airplane? Both please. Both.
好了，萨姆。萨姆和我两个人都满怀期待地把身子往前探。兴奋得身体都快颤抖了。好吧。你们有个选择。你们想听我命名为“周年纪念”的那篇，还是想听我命名为“飞机”的那篇？两篇都要，拜托。两篇。
I must be selfish. Okay. Let's start with anniversary. September 10th, 1996. Oh my gosh. I don't like what this is. Yeah. 1.28pm.
我这个人比较贪心。好吧。我们从“周年纪念”开始。1996年9月10日。噢天哪。我不太喜欢这篇的内容。对。下午1点28分。
PM is underlined. Oh. Just so you know. Today marks my one year anniversary in Los Angeles, California exclamation point. Can you believe it? Question exclamation point. Time has flown here. It crawled in New York.
下午的英文缩写PM下面还画了下划线。哦。以防你们想知道。今天是我在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶的一周年纪念日，感叹号。你敢相信吗？问号加感叹号。这里的时光飞逝。在纽约时，日子过得度日如年。
I haven't accomplished a great deal yet. Or have I accomplished a lot? Why is it in a riddle? The next part is so embarrassing. What is it? Oh gosh. Angela is wiping tears from her eyes. Because it's so dorky.
我还没有取得太大的成就。或者说我已经成就了很多？为什么写得像个谜语？接下来这部分太尴尬了。是什么？哦天哪。安吉拉正擦拭着眼角的泪水。因为太书呆子气了。
Such a dork. I'm still a dork. Okay. I haven't accomplished a great deal yet. Or I have accomplished a lot. On whose measure am I judged? It's written in Game of Thrones. Oh my goodness.
简直是个书呆子。我到现在还是个书呆子。好吧。我还没有取得太大的成就。或者说我已经成就了很多？我该以谁的标准来衡量自己？这写得简直像《权力的游戏》。哦天哪。
Oh God. All right. That's how that one ends. Okay. Okay. Next one. Let's see the date here. December 24th, 1996.
哦天哪。好吧，这篇就这样结束了。好吧。好吧。下一篇。看看这里的日期。1996年12月24日。
Christmas Eve Delta Airlines. Oh. Okay. Okay. 516 p.m. Utah Airport. I just got bumped up to first class exclamation point. What a nice Christmas present.
平安夜，达美航空。哦。好吧。好吧。下午5点16分。犹他机场。我刚刚被升到了头等舱，感叹号。多么棒的圣诞礼物啊。
Exclamation point. Fun exclamation point. This has never happened to me. I am so psyched. A window seat in first class makes up for that two and a half hour layover in Salt Lake City. I'm drinking my complimentary pre-flight drink. Oh, and in first class you get a hot meal. Ha.
感叹号。太棒了，感叹号。这种事从来没发生在我身上。我太兴奋了。头等舱靠窗的座位总算弥补了我在盐湖城那两个半小时的转机等待。我正在喝我的免费登机前饮品。哦，在头等舱里你还能吃上一顿热乎的饭菜。哈。
Economy gets a sack lunch. Oh my gosh. Now you get nothing. I know. I wonder if they upgraded me because I don't feel well. My cold is getting worse. How would they know? Did you tell someone?
经济舱只有一袋午餐盒。哦天哪。现在你们什么都没有了。我懂。我在想他们是不是因为我感觉不舒服才给我升舱的？我的感冒越来越严重了。他们怎么会知道？你跟别人说了吗？
I feel pretty sick. My nose is driving me crazy and dripping a lot. Did you go to the airport and go, I'm so sorry about you. I don't feel well. Well, first class rocks, but I feel really sick. I might be getting the flu. You know what? I want to see the journal entry of the person who sat next to you on this flight.
我感觉病得挺重的。我的鼻子快把我折磨疯了，一直在流鼻涕。你是不是去机场然后对别人说，我真的很抱歉，我感觉不太舒服？好吧，头等舱太酷了，但我真的感觉很不舒服。我可能要得流感了。你知道吗？真想看看坐在你旁边的那位乘客的日记。
The first time paying for first class and they seat me next to some sniffly runny nose. Why died weirdo who's downing a drink pre-flight? She keeps telling the flight attendants are sick. All right. The stewardess is the nicest lady. She's really taking good care of me. I'm pretty sure now I have a fever. I'm getting worse.
第一次花钱坐头等舱，结果航空公司把我安排在一个又吸鼻子又流鼻涕、一直在登机前狂灌酒的怪咖旁边？她还一直在告诉空乘自己生病了。好吧。空姐是个极好的人。她把我照顾得很好。现在我基本确定自己发烧了。我病情加重了。
This is now two hours into the flight. Oh goodness. This is how it ends. Filling so sickly, exclamation point, sad face. Oh yeah. There you go. Did you have the flu? Yeah, I got the flu.
这已经是起飞后两小时了。哦天哪。日记就是这样结尾的。感觉糟透了，感叹号，悲伤的表情。哦，是的。就是这样。你当时得流感了吗？对，我得了流感。
I showed up on Christmas Eve with the flu. I like that it has callbacks. You're like, not like the other airport as if we're going to be like, ah, I remember that entry. Wait, I didn't count on this one. But here is January 2, 1997. Well, 1997 is here. Can you believe it? You and the reader have been through so much.
我在平安夜带着流感现身了。我喜欢这种前后呼应的感觉。你当时的语气就像是，跟别的机场可不一样，好像我们都会记得一样：“啊，我记得那篇日记。”等等，我没想到还有这篇。不过这里是1997年1月2日。好吧，1997年到了。你敢相信吗？你和读者一起经历了这么多。
Oh gosh. All right. I'm going to stop for today. My journals are so embarrassing. Thank you so much for that. Well, that was delightful, Angela. And I just want to say we do also have the option of a spinoff podcast called Angela's Journal. No, no.
哦天哪。好吧。我今天就读到这里。我的日记太尴尬了。非常感谢你读这些。好吧，那真是太美妙了，安吉拉。我只想说，我们其实还有一个推出衍生播客的选择，叫做《安吉拉的日记》。不，不。
We can't take it. I'm just saying as we figure out what's next. No. You can break down a journal entry each episode. Oh. Deep dives on it. I mean, who am I writing to always is the question. Okay.
我们绝不能接这个。我只是说，当我们考虑接下来要做什么的时候。不。你可以每一集分析一篇日记。哦。进行深度挖掘。我的天，我到底是在写给谁看呢，这真是一直以来的问题。好吧。
I'm sorry you were sick that Christmas. I know. That really stinks. But I did get to fly first class. You did? Yeah. The bus is on the road and Toby has made it inside the church, finally. And we had a fan catch from Sean L in Indiana.
我很遗憾那个圣诞节你生病了。我知道。那真的太糟糕了。但我确实坐过头等舱了。你坐过？对。大巴已经在路上了，托比终于进了教堂。我们收到了来自印第安纳州肖恩·L的粉丝抓包。
It's wonderful. Sean said, this is not a question, but something fun to look out for. When Toby enters the church toward the end of the episode, you can see Dwight put his business cards inside of the Bibles in the pews. Oh Sean, this is something I was about to bring up. Yes. It's at 15 minutes and 50 seconds. You can see Dwight's little business card popping out of the Bible.
太棒了。肖恩说：“这不是一个问题，而是一个值得留意的有趣细节。当托比在剧集接近尾声时走进教堂时，你可以看到德怀特把他的名片塞进了长椅上的圣经里。”哦，肖恩，正是我要提这件事。是的。在15分50秒时。你可以看到德怀特的小名片从圣经里露出来。
That's right. In deleted scenes, there is a scene. You go to the DVD, Dwight is stuffing all of the Bibles and hymnals in all the pews with his business card. Incredible. Well, Jim is panicking. He cannot find CeCe and someone says a little blonde lady took CeCe. Yes.
没错。在被删减的片段里有这么一幕。如果你去看DVD，德怀特正在把所有长椅上的圣经和赞美诗集里都塞满他的名片。太绝了。好吧，吉姆现在急疯了。他找不到西西，有人说有个金发小个子女人把西西抱走了。是的。
That little blonde lady is Pam's mother, but Jim doesn't know that. So just as Pam is entering with a tray of sub sandwiches, Jim screams, stop that woman. Stop her now, she stole my baby. Kevin grabs Angela and her big bag right as Pam is entering and they all collide and this tray of sub sandwiches goes flying in the air. Jenna, this was like a stunt for us. Do you remember? I do remember.
那个金发小个子女人是帕姆的妈妈，但吉姆不知道这一点。所以就在帕姆端着一托盘潜艇堡走进来的时候，吉姆大喊：“拦住那个女人。马上拦住她，她偷了我的孩子。”就在帕姆进门时，凯文撞上了安吉拉和她那个大包，两人撞成一团，托盘上的潜艇堡飞上了天。詹娜，这对我们来说就像拍动作特技一样。你还记得吗？我当然记得。
They had to break it down. We had to time it out. Someone was queuing you on the outside. Brian had to be in the right place and I did and you had to come in. I'm not going to lie. When I watched it, I thought my like tray fumble was a little forced. I don't know if you saw it like brought the two trays together almost like symbols. It looked like a cartoon.
他们必须把动作拆解开来。我们必须掐准时间。外面有人在给暗号。布莱恩必须在正确的位置，我必须在正确的位置，而你必须走进来。我不撒谎。当我看到成品时，我觉得我的托盘掉落显得有点刻意。我不知道你有没有看到，我几乎像敲镲一样把两个托盘撞在了一起。看起来就像动画片。
It looked like Looney Tunes. It looked like so crazy. And I also wanted to know why the silver platter. I don't know. She would be bringing them in in bags. This whole silver platter thing was so over the top. Well, we got a fan question from Kirsten W in Fort Myers, Florida, who said, when Pam comes back from getting the subs, she drops them when Angela bumps into her
看起来像《乐一通》。看起来太疯狂了。而且我也想知道为什么要用银盘子。不知道。她本来应该用袋子把它们带进来的。整个用银盘子装简直太夸张了。好吧，我们收到了来自佛罗里达州麦尔斯堡的克斯滕·W的一个粉丝提问，她说，当帕姆买完潜艇堡回来时，被安吉拉撞到后把三明治摔了，然后他们暗示因为三明治掉在地上所以没法吃了。但所有的潜艇堡都是包起来的啊。那他们为什么不直接捡起来吃呢？我同意。
and then they insinuate that they can't eat the subs because they fell on the ground. But all the subs were wrapped. So why couldn't they just pick them up and eat them? I agree. Yeah, I thought the same thing at first. But then I remembered that we were implying in our blocking that we were like stomping on them, like when they were on the ground. They got tripped on and stepped on.
是的，我一开始也这么想。但后来我记起我们在排练走位时暗示过，我们当时好像是在踩它们，就当它们掉在地上的时候。它们被绊倒并踩到了。
Yeah. Because of the whole struggle with Kevin and Angela and the purse and the scones. Yes, that was the idea. But like I said, I'm not sure we sold the moment as well as we could have. I want to tell you who is selling the moment. There is a background actor behind Angela and Kevin while they're struggling with Angela's purse and the scones and all of that. He gave me life.
对。因为和凯文、安吉拉、钱包以及司康饼有一场混战。是的，当时的设计是这样的。但就像我说的，我不确定我们把那一刻表现得足够完美。我想告诉你们谁才是在完美演绎那一刻。在安吉拉和凯文争夺安吉拉的钱包、司康饼和所有这一切的时候，安吉拉和凯文身后有一个背景演员。他简直给了我无限欢乐。
He is so horrified by this behavior. Oh my goodness. I wish I could see that. It's so good. And I was like so tickled by it. Well, Kevin's going to go through Angela's bag thinking he's going to find a baby. But what he does find is thousands of scones and Angela's bag. Thousands.
他被这种行为吓坏了。哦天哪。我真希望我也能看到那一幕。太精彩了。我当时觉得好笑极了。好吧，凯文开始翻安吉拉的包，以为他会找到一个婴儿。但他实际上在安吉拉的包里找到了成千上万个司康饼。成千上万个。
Thousands. Thousands. All the scones basically. Sconesy cider is not happy. Angela's the new sconesy cider. We got mail about this scone theft. Oh, yeah. Sarah M. from Harrisburg, Pennsylvania said,
成千上万。基本全是司康饼。斯康西·西代尔肯定不会高兴。安吉拉成了新一代的斯康西·西代尔。我们收到了关于这场偷司康饼事件的邮件。哦，是的。宾夕法尼亚州哈里斯堡的萨拉·M说，
I never understood why Angela took all the scones. Did she do it to sabotage the christening luncheon? And then Susanna H. from Clermont, Florida said, Hot take. I think Angela stole the scones to make Pam and Jim look even worse for having so little food. I don't think she even likes scones. Angela, what's your take? Strong words.
我一直不明白为什么安吉拉要拿走所有的司康饼。她是为了破坏洗礼午宴吗？然后，来自佛罗里达州克莱蒙特的苏珊娜·H说：“大胆猜测，我认为安吉拉偷司康饼是为了让帕姆和吉姆因为食物太少而显得更丢脸。我觉得她甚至根本不喜欢司康饼。”安吉拉，你怎么看？措辞真激烈。
Well, are you a saboteur? I don't think she's a saboteur. I think she might just be that person that takes extra roles when they leave a party or a few extra party favors or if you have fruit set out, she might take some of your bananas and apples. I think she might be that person. Well, before we're done closing out this reception, there was a deleted scene I'd like to talk about that happened at the reception.
好吧，你是个蓄意破坏者吗？我不认为她是蓄意破坏者。我觉得她可能只是那种在离开派对时会顺走额外食物、多拿几个派对纪念品，或者如果你摆出了水果，她可能会顺走你的一些香蕉和苹果的那种人。我觉得她可能就是那样的人。好吧，在我们结束这场招待会之前，有一个我想聊聊的被删减片段，它发生在招待会上。
It was sort of the end of the day and a lot of people had left and Jim and Pam finally got the small intimate gathering they were hoping for and Jim gives a really sweet speech. I thought we should hear it. We're gonna have your attention. Today, we christened our daughter, Cecilia Marie. And yeah, from a moment there, I thought she was bailing on her own reception, but I guess she decided to stick it out.
那可以说是接近一天结束的时候，许多人都已经离开了，吉姆和帕姆终于迎来了他们一直期盼的温馨小聚，吉姆发表了一段非常感人的演讲。我想我们应该听听看。大家请安静一下。今天，我们为我们的女儿塞西莉亚·玛丽举行了洗礼。是的，有一会儿我还以为她想逃掉自己的招待会呢，不过我想她最后还是决定坚持下来。
We named CeCe after Pam's grandmother, Cecilia, and after my grandmother, Marie. And I always remember how cool Marie was. She loved people and she loved a full and crazy house and nothing ever rattled her. So she would have loved it here today. And we just hope that CeCe has that same carefree spirit. Thank you guys all for coming and sharing this special day with us.
我们给西西取名是为了纪念帕姆的祖母塞西莉亚，以及我的祖母玛丽。我一直记得玛丽是多么酷的一个人。她热爱人们，她喜欢热闹疯狂的家，没有什么能把她难倒。所以她一定会喜欢今天这里的场景。我们只是希望西西也能拥有那种无忧无虑的精神。谢谢大家今天能来，与我们一同分享这个特殊的日子。
Who wants to go pick up Michael and Andy? Okay, so that's how that really sweet speech ends. And when Pam says who wants to go pick up Michael and Andy, Aaron flies out of her seat, doesn't say anything to Gabe or anyone and sprints out the door. Wow. Yeah. Hmm.
谁想去接迈克尔和安迪？好吧，那段非常感人的演讲就是这样结束的。当帕姆问“谁想去接迈克尔和安迪”时，艾琳直接从座位上弹了起来，对加布或其他任何人什么都没说，飞奔着冲出了大门。哇。是的。嗯。
But wasn't that a sweet speech? That was really sweet. And we found out sort of inspiration for the baby's name. I love that. Well, I guess we should go to the bus because Michael and Andy are regretting their decision. It's going to take two days to get there. Their next stop is Tennessee.
不过那段演讲是不是很感人？真的很感人。而且我们知道了这个婴儿名字的灵感来源。我太喜欢了。好吧，我想我们该去大巴那儿了，因为迈克尔和安迪开始后悔他们的决定了。去那里需要整整两天时间。他们的下一站是田纳西州。
Yeah. Michael and Andy went off the bus. They're changing their minds. Full stop. And they asked the bus driver to stop the bus. The bus driver was played by Terry James. You know, Randy said that Alice and Jones read stunt drivers for this role. They had to hold a certain category license because he was really hoping
是的。迈克尔和安迪下了大巴。他们改变主意了。彻底不去了。他们要求大巴司机停车。大巴司机由特里·詹姆斯饰演。你知道，兰迪说艾莉森·琼斯曾为这个角色物色过特技司机。他们必须持有某种特定类别的驾照，因为他真的很希望
that the person they cast as this actor could actually drive the bus. So our stunt coordinator, Wally Crowder, suggested Terry James. He read for the role. He did great. And he could really drive during this scene. I thought Terry did so great. I loved it when he said, you shouldn't talk to a bus driver. Yes.
他们选中的这个演员能够真正开大巴。所以我们的特技统筹沃利·克劳德推荐了特里·詹姆斯。他来试镜了这个角色。他表现得棒极了。而且他在拍摄这场戏时确实能亲自开车。我觉得特里表现得太棒了。我特别喜欢他说：“你不应该跟大巴司机说话。”是的。
Well, they start making a scene. They're screaming, stop the bus, stop the bus. Andy is, I mean, he's like starting to cry. And the young kids that are on the bus are like, what's going on, you guys? What's happening? Yeah. The female student was played by Erica Merr. And then the other gentleman, the kind of scraggly haired fella,
好吧，他们开始大闹了。他们尖叫着“停车，停车”。安迪——我的意思是，他开始哭了。大巴上的年轻人都在说：“怎么回事啊你们？发生什么事了？”对。女学生由埃里卡·梅尔饰演。然后另一位男士，那个头发有点蓬乱的家伙，
we got some mail about him. And that led me down a road. Zian from Amarillo, Texas said, my brother-in-law had a small guest spot in this episode. His name is Seth Allison. He is the youth group kid with the scraggly hair that says, are you coming with us and stop the dang bus? He is still in Hollywood working in comedy. In fact, he was on an episode of the gong show that Ed Helms judged.
我们收到了一些关于他的邮件。这引领我走上了一条奇妙的道路。来自德克萨斯州阿马里洛的齐安说：“我姐夫在这集里有个小客串角色。他叫塞思·埃利森。他就是那个留着蓬乱头发、说‘你们要跟我们一起去吗’和‘把该死的大巴停下’的青年团契孩子。他现在仍然在好莱坞从事喜剧工作。事实上，他曾出现在一集由埃德·赫尔姆斯担任评委的《锣秀》节目中。”
He has also been on America's Got Talent several times and traveled to other countries to be on their versions of the show. His stage name is Sethward. Angela. Sethward. Yeah. Has appeared on 12 episodes of America's Got Talent over multiple seasons. Wow.
他还曾多次参加《美国达人秀》，并前往其他国家参加他们当地版本的节目。他的艺名叫塞思沃德。安吉拉。塞思沃德。对。他在多个季度中出演了12集《美国达人秀》。哇。
Five episodes of the gong show. He always appears as a type of animal who, I don't know how to explain it, but he has been Sethward the worm, Sethward the phoenix, Sethward the peacock, Sethward the walrus, the caterpillar, the snake, the chicken, the cow, and the bunny. What does he do when he's an animal? Well, it's very interesting. So the first one that I saw was Sethward the caterpillar. Okay.
5集《锣秀》。他每次登场都扮演某种动物，我不知道该怎么解释，但他扮演过塞思沃德虫子、塞思沃德火凤凰、塞思沃德孔雀、塞思沃德海象、毛毛虫、蛇、小鸡、母牛和兔子。他扮演动物时都在干什么？好吧，这非常有趣。所以我看到的第一个是塞思沃德毛毛虫。好吧。
He is in a caterpillar outfit and when he comes out onto the stage, he falls down. He rolls off the stage and then he goes up on the stage and he goes through a metamorphosis and turns into a butterfly, but they didn't let him finish. They judged him out. Oh. But he became sort of like an audience favorite. So he came back multiple times. Finally, they let him move forward, but he was just a recurring fan favorite of the show.
他穿着一套毛毛虫服装，当他走到舞台上时，他摔倒了。他从舞台上滚了下去，然后又爬上舞台，经历了一场变态发育，变成了一只蝴蝶，但他们没让他演完。评委按铃淘汰了他。哦。但他不知怎么成了观众的最爱。所以他多次回归。最后，他们让他晋级了，但他只是成了节目中一个常驻的粉丝最爱。
Yes. Of America's Got Talent coming back in different forms every time. I went down a rabbit hole. I watched all of his appearances. Is it lots of like physical comedy? Yes. Yes. But also just very charming and funny.
是的。作为《美国达人秀》的常客，每次都以不同的形态回归。我陷入了一个信息深渊。我看完了他所有的出场视频。里面有很多形体喜剧吗？是的。是的。但同时也非常迷人且搞笑。
I'll have to check it out, Sethward. Well, they finally stopped the bus and let them off and we see that they call someone to come get them and it is Aaron. Yes. And another student gets off the bus with them too. That's right. He's like, don't tell my parents. That student was played by Jeff Loveness.
我得去看看这个塞思沃德。好吧，他们终于把大巴停下来让他们下了车，我们看到他们打电话叫人来接他们，来的人是艾琳。是的。另一个学生也跟他们一起下了大巴。没错。他说：“别告诉我爸妈。”那个学生由杰夫·洛文尼斯饰演。
He's a writer performer. He's worked on Rick and Morty, the Onion News Network and has been a writer for the Emmys and Oscar televised programs. We got some fan mail from Alania D in Wisconsin and Lauren H in Santa Clarita, California, who both pointed out that he looks a lot like Steve Carell. They thought he looked like Steve's teenage doppelganger. They wanted to know if he was related to Steve, but he's not. No, no, he's not.
他是一位编剧兼表演者。他曾参与过《瑞克和莫蒂》、洋葱新闻网的工作，并担任过艾美奖和奥斯卡电视转播节目的编剧。我们收到了来自威斯康星州的阿拉尼亚·D和圣克拉丽塔的劳伦·H的粉丝来信，她们都指出他长得非常像史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。她们觉得他看起来像是史蒂夫的青少年替身。她们想知道他是不是和史蒂夫有什么亲戚关系，但并不是。不，不，他不是。
I kind of see it. Well, they're going to get in with Aaron and Michael wants to know is the reception still going on and she said, no, most everyone left. In fact, I think they all went to see a movie and Michael got what he wanted. Everyone's hanging out. They're having a memory together. And he's very happy to be back in this country. Yes, the country he never left.
我确实觉得有点像。好吧，他们上了艾琳的车，迈克尔想知道招待会还在继续吗，她说：“没有，几乎所有人都走了。事实上，我想他们都去看电影了。”而迈克尔得到了他想要的结果。每个人都在一起聚会。他们共同创造了一段回忆。他非常高兴能回到这片土地上。是的，这片他从来没离开过的土地。
That's right. Well, that was christening, everybody. Thank you so much to Randy Cordray for sharing behind the scenes details with us. And thank you, James Carey, for sending me over those call sheets. Sam and Cassie, you guys are the best. Thanks for sitting through my journal entry. And Jenna, I can't wait to open letters with my letter opener. I can't wait to watch you do it.
没错。好吧，这就是洗礼这一集的内容，各位。非常感谢兰迪·科德雷与我们分享幕后细节。也谢谢詹姆斯·凯里把那些通告单发给我。萨姆和卡西，你们俩是最棒的。谢谢你们听我读日记。詹娜，我已经迫不及待要用开信刀拆信了。我迫不及待想看你这么做。
It will bring me joy. Have a great week, you guys. We'll see you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer.
这会给我带来快乐。祝大家这周过得愉快。我们下期再见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音师是萨姆·基弗。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需收听无广告版本的“办公室女士”，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 注册即可享受一个月的免费试用，优惠码为 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。